this week's 48 Hours features a woman
accused of attempted murder with a very
unusual weapon investigators say
Victoria nazarova used a poison piece of
cheesecake the motive authorities say
she wanted to kill her look-alike which
is a New York Beauty Stylist in order to
steal her identity for eight hours
correspondent Peter Van Sant has our
report
Victoria nazarova is a suspect detective
Kevin Rogers says he can't forget hands
down one of the craziest cases that I've
ever had to deal with it began on
September 2nd 2016. when Rogers went to
the Queen's home of a 35 year old woman
a Beauty Stylist named Olga who
said she had been robbed Olga said
nazarova who looks a lot like her had
come to her house after begging for a
last-minute Beauty appointment nazarova
brought cheesecake with her and insisted
Olga try it and what happened I got sick
Olga says She fainted and then nearly
died at the hospital but for months
Rogers couldn't find nazarova turns out
he wasn't the only one looking former
New York detective turned private
investigator Herman Weisberg says
Victoria was wanted for a murder in
Russia Weisberg noticed on Facebook
Victoria had posted pictures that
offered Clues to her location in New
York the stitching on that back headrest
remarkably Weisberg was able to match
this stitching and dashboard see the
dashboard of the car to a Chrysler 300
and this photo see that telephone pole
reflected a particular building in
Brooklyn you got the telephone pole and
the two manhole covers surveillance
confirmed nazarova was there in March
2017 NYPD arrested her but to make a
case against nazareova detective Rogers
needed to find out what was in that
cheesecake he sent the container he'd
collected from Olga's apartment out for
testing and got a hit it's phenazepam in
the cheesecake a potentially lethal
sedative in Victoria's apartment police
found a motive Olga's ID I think she
wanted to kill this woman and assume her
identity
and Peter VanZant joins us now Peter
good morning I mean well done on scaring
every dessert lover audience had
investigators ever seen anything like
this before this was the first for me
and it was a first for them they've seen
people use you know knives and guns and
clubs and machetes eye drops even
rattlesnakes to kill people but never
cheesecake this is a first well they did
kind of look alike they looked very much
like we have other photographs in the
course of this hour they they look like
twins and she just wanted to assume her
identity because she was wanted for
murder she just wanted for murder wrong
with people Peter I I know it's hard
it's terrible and Olga is such a
sweetheart in the course of this case
and the fact that this happened to her
she survived thank goodness but a
harrowing experience you've also spoke
with the suspect nazareova in this what
was she like what did she tell you
nazareova is a clever and Charming
disarming she's very confident she
looked at me and she said Peter I am not
killer I am I am woman that's what she
said that's what she said Peter said
you know I obviously challenge her
heavily during the course of this but
it's that confidence and her ability to
manipulate that cops say she targeted
primarily married men in this business
uh criminal Enterprise that she had
because she drugged them steal from them
and who are they going to tell their
wives that they were out with this other
woman so they would never report the
crimes and she may have had dozens of
victims in the New York City area so
there's another twist which is uh the
private eye found nazareova using a
reflection in her sunglasses this is
incredible what does that mean what do
you mean she wore reflector sunglasses
and she would take selfies and post them
on Facebook here's a woman wanted for
murder and she's actually posting
pictures with her identity in the New
York City area and so he studies these
glasses and in it he sees the reflection
of the car she's in so he learns that
and the apartment building that she
lives in is reflected they find that and
it helps lead to her arrest there's also
a woman in the case this is really
important she's convinced that nazareova
murdered her mother
she launched her own investigation got
traffic camera photographs that show her
passed out mother in the front seat of a
car with nazareova driving and she
solved that case too so amazing
nazareova has her day in court very good
detective work though that's good yeah
very good he tells me he goes I never
look at just the face I look at
everything around and that's how he
finds much more to see Peter Van Zandt
great to see you thanks for this you can
see his full report the case of the
poison cheesecake on 48 hours tomorrow
night at 10 9 Central here on CBS and of
course on Paramount Plus